vous vivez les mêmes galères
vu les mêmes choses le quotidien il est
pas facile émotion incompréhension et
prévention la maman de Djibril a tenu à
s'adresser aux jeunes qu'il soit de mort
pas de Coignières ou encore de la
verrière ils sont tous touchés par la
disparition de son fils de 14 ans
assassiné il y a deux semaines il a
grandi ici son père il a grandi à
Élancourt son grand-père il habite à la
verrière et il a des cousins à Trappes
donc il a des copains partout partout la
des copains de Djibril et il a pas il
avait pas de problème
particulière avec les autres pour rendre
hommage à son enfant une marche blanche
a été organisée au départ du gymnase du
moulin à vent à Coignières jusqu'au
stade du bois à Maurepas plus de 1000
personnes ont participé à ce moment de
recueillement mais je le connaissais
ouais on se voyait tous les jours je
vais donner des conseils je lui crier
dessus voilà je suis ami avec son père
le jeune je le connais pas
personnellement mais j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont amenés avec lui qui sont
danseurs avec moi un soutien à la
famille parce que ce qui s'est passé
franchement c'est une admissible un
jeune de 14 ans qui est décédé
franchement c'est c'est
une magie noble une atmosphère
silencieuse calme et apaisée entourée ce
rendez-vous en présence des mers des
deux communes liées par ce drame mais il
suffit pas de dire plus jamais ça pour
que ça n'arrive plus il faut
effectivement mettre en place les
mesures qui s'imposent et il faut
effectivement que l'éducation je l'ai
dit dans mon discours il faut que
l'éducation redevienne véritablement la
priorité des priorités parce que ce
n'est que parler d'éducation que nous en
sortirons c'est pas par la répression on
le sait très bien pour rappel
l'adolescent a été tué lors d'une rixe
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 novembre devant
le gymnase du moulin à vent en marge
d'un événement de MMA